let's talk about trump
versus mcconnell the the the fight we've
all been waiting on
donald trump rips mitch mcconnell as he
seeks to exert leadership after the
impeachment trial donald trump attacked
senate minority leader that's a new
title for him
minority leader mitch mcconnell the
gop's highest-ranking elected official
after comments he made about trump's
culpability for the insurrection
at the u.s capitol on january 6. the
republican party
can never be respected or strong with
political leaders like senator mitch
mcconnell at its helm
did you hear that quote right there the
republic the republican party
can never again be respected or strong
with political leaders like mcconnell i
mean this is
gloves are off they are talking trash
the statement came
three days after mcconnell criticized
trump over the attack on the capital
although he voted to acquit him at the
impeachment trial
mcconnell said he did so because he did
not think it was constitutional to hold
an impeachment trial for a former
president the senate republican leader
held trump responsible for the attack
saying his false claims of fraud in the
election he lost to joe biden
inspired extremist followers to commit
violence to insurrection as he's talking
about
quote-unquote from mcconnell this was an
intensifying
crescendo of conspiracy theories
orchestrated by an outgoing president
who seemed determined
to either overturn the voters decisions
or else
torch our institutions on the way out
this is mcconnell versus trump here's
what
this amazing what you have here is
mcconnell who believes in institutions i
mean mcconnell he looks like a turtle
he's got you know
you know you can say go go on but one
thing he does respect
is the rule of law and institutions and
he's basically called out trump
saying you don't respect either of that
you don't respect the people you don't
respect institutions
came out and just ripped in to did you
see the speech
mcconnell yeah mcconnell's speech he
ripped into trump but then obviously in
typical
mcconnell fashion voted not to impeach
him you know because you can't
and pg um non-sitting president but
non-sitting president
so then trump basically came out and he
said listen
with leaders like this guy the
republican party ain't going nowhere so
whose side you got
you got trump's side you on mcconnell's
side you got to pick a side well with
trump you get the highlights you get the
bluster so
here he he called him he called
mcconnell a a dower
sullen an unsmiling political hack i
mean that's good writing i got to give
him credit for that i mean he didn't
say those words those are the examples
he didn't come up with those words so
maybe he did i'm not sure though
what was the quote he called mcconnell a
dour sullen
and unsmiling politicians we've heard
we've heard donald trump speak
okay he's never used a doubt but here's
the thing
he's like he's a loser he's not saying
those words but you know donald trump
isn't just doing this for you know to
get his name out there
there's more to this and one of his
problems with mcconnell
is his wife elaine chao right who served
in the cabinet as the
uh transportation secretary so he felt
because of the influence of his wife on
mcconnell
that he's they're incapable of being
tough on china and that was
basically the crux of his argument once
you get past the personal attack
you think this is somehow related to
china with the mcconnell and he
remarried an asian woman
here's a quote you know trump literally
said this in this release he goes
likewise mcconnell has no credibility on
china because of his family's
substantial chinese business holdings
and he went in there to talk about and
in mcconnell's wife but he selected her
to be part of his cabinet so he knew
what he was doing he looked at her and
he said yep you're from china what's up
let's do it yeah so
the rest of his quote was he will never
do what needs to be done or what is
right for our country where necessary
and appropriate i will
back primary rivals who espouse making
america great again so this this
but but he just won the reelection he's
going to be there for another what six
years how long you
i mean no he that this is a quote from
trump in here so that's what i'm saying
about mcconnell primary rivals but
mcconnell just re-elected no what
trump's saying here is where necessary
and appropriate i will back
primary rivals who espouse making
america great again in our policy of
america first so
he's saying you know mcconnell disciples
he's going to put money in to get them
out
like they're they're not good for the
republicans mcconnell disciples yeah so
you ask yourself is this trump trying to
flex a little bit and say i am going to
be impactful over the next few years
i am going to have a say in this next
election if i'm not running myself
i'm going to be the leader of this
republican party and i think that's part
of it
and then the last thing is you had to
ask yourself how's trump going to
communicate
without twitter and he did this all on a
release essentially
that he sent to the media he'll figure
out a way and he still got his message
out right
who's got more control currently in the
republican party currently mcconnell or
trump well i mean
mcconnell has it inside washington d.c
but you
have who's got the support i don't know
that'll we'll find out but
trump's got the base obviously he still
hasn't mcconnell's got his question
what do you think what do you think
about i mean i think i think it all
comes down to control
obviously it seems like mcconnell's
trying to get past the trump era and
return to normalcy if you want
uh trump's trying to stay relevant he's
trying to stay
influential whether he's just trying to
stay
stay relevant enough to have a good
position to run in 2024 or if he's
trying to
full-on become the godfather of a new
republican party uh
i mean we'll kind of have to wait and
see but it seems like there's
uh obviously an argument there and trump
does still have
money that he they didn't use on the
campaign i think it was like
a 100 billion or something like that
renovate a few hotels what couldn't you
no uh i think 30 billion or something
these are the things to do with the
money this is uh this is his campaign
that he yeah the warchest that he never
uh fully went into what's he gonna do
with it he can
he can he can promote campaigns for
rivals of uh
of mcconnell's p peeps uh just can't
build a hotel
no no yeah he can't he can't use it they
tore down his atlantic city because yeah
today
yesterday okay yesterday uh so this is
gonna be interesting if the republican
party ever wants to get back into
the good graces or in the white house
would you not think that trump and
mcconnell are gonna have to kind of
work together on this right i don't know
if mcconnell is going to be here that
much longer maybe
but i think it answers a bigger question
too is is trump going to be able to
communicate
now it's different than twitter where
it's non-stop and it's constant and
this was 622 words this statement right
how many words can you do on a tweet
right now this would take a few tweets
it would take a while so he's still able
to get his message out but it just
doesn't like
bombard the day and stop everybody in
their tracks i mean he might be able to
get one or two of these out a week
as opposed to every hour he's sending a
message like he used to
um a little segue here you know whose
opinion i would actually genuinely love
to have heard on this would have been
rush limbaugh's
respect to the uh to rush limbaugh he
was in the news
recently passed away at 70 years old it
was um was it lung cancer
um after a year long he last year he
received the presidential medal of
freedom
we're not going to go too deep on this
topic but this is a topic that he would
have a field day with mcconnell
who he's been you know outspoken for
against for years he was obviously a big
trump advocate
uh he would have been an interesting
opinion on this but the mcconnell
trump battle is i think something that
will be continuing for the years to come
i don't think either of them are done
weighing in on uh
on everything that happened but
mcconnell was very clear he said trump
you did this you promoted the lies you
were the conspiracy theorist
you provided the fuel to the fire of the
insurrectionists who raided the capital
and i think that mcconnell at the end of
the day
um believes in institutions so it'll be
interesting to see
where that goes so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye